le maroc se dote d'un nouveau
gouvernement après les législatives du 8
septembre le milliardaire abdel aziz
akhannouch emmené le premier ministre
sont partis deux heures à nicher un
rassemblement national des indépendants
est le grand vainqueur du scrutin et le
nouvel exécutif aura de nombreuses
missions on en parle justement avec
notre correspondant au maghreb bassam
chips
24 nouveaux ministres dont sept femmes
composent l'équipe d'abdel aziz
akhannouch le nouveau chef du
gouvernement considéré comme proche du
roi mois métis qui aura la lourde tâche
de redresser le pays durement touché par
la crise du coronavirus et les
inégalités sociales qui ont marqué
l'ancien gouvernement de saad eddine el
othmani dans ce nouveau gouvernement qui
compte double de fun que dans l'ancienne
équipe les portefeuilles régaliens sont
reconduits à l'image de ceux de
l'intérieur et des affaires étrangères
tous deux entre les mains de nasser
bourita ya des lois fille la petite
après la victoire de son parti le
rassemblement national des indépendants
l'homme d'affaires avait annoncé le 22
septembre dernier être parvenu à la
formation d'un gouvernement de trois
parties le sien qui raflent 102 sièges
que compte et 395 du parlement marocain
le parti authenticité et modernité avec
86 sièges et istiqlal avec 81 sièges
c'est un nouveau cabinet un mix entre
des ministres chevronnés et des jeunes
compétences le gouvernement se base sur
deux piliers les programmes des trois
partis qui composent le cabinet ainsi
que les conclusions du nouveau modèle de
développement
la priorité aujourd'hui est le programme
gouvernemental qui est prêt et qui sera
présenté au parlement pour obtenir le
vote de confiance
125 sièges il y a quelques mois contre
12 aujourd'hui les islamistes modérés du
parti de la justice et du développement
à la tête du royaume depuis plus de dix
ans apparaissent comme les grands
perdants de ce scrutin au profit des
libéraux considéré comme proche de la
couronne nouveau chef du gouvernement
devra présenter son programme dans les
jours à venir devant la chambre des
représentants afin d'obtenir sa
confiance une formalité politique comme
le veut la constitution du royaume du
maroc